welcome to weekly ticket work-from-home
edition I'm Tracee Ellis Ross from the
Heine yo what's up - selling the ice
cube checked out our new movie the high
note on Fandango now May 29 4 we talked
to Tracy Ellis Ross Ice Cube and Dakota
Johnson about their new film here's the
top movie news we start off with the
fact that Legally Blonde 3 is officially
happening Mindy Kaling and Dan gore have
signed on to write the screenplay for
the MGM film that will be produced
through Reese Witherspoon's production
company hello sunshine
Witherspoon will indeed reprise her role
as Elle Woods and even shared her
excitement over the news with a
side-by-side pic on Instagram of her
character Elle Woods and Mindy Kaling
copying the look next up Peter Dinklage
and Jason Momoa are set to star in a
vampire movie titled good bad and undead
Dinklage will play van Helsing the last
in a long line of vampire hunters who
has an uneasy partnership with a vampire
played by Momoa who has taken a vow to
never kill again together they run a
scam from town to town where van Helsing
pretends to vanquish the vampire for
money but when a massive bounty is put
on the vampire's head everything in this
dangerous world full of monsters and
magic is now after them max Barbic how
the filmmaker behind the Sundance hit
Palm Springs is set to direct while
Momoa will serve as hunky producer sorry
just regular producer just a producer
and Tony McNamara is reteaming with your
go slant the most for a gothic Western
titled hook line monster the duo who
previously worked on the favorite will
now adapt the gothic Western novel by
Richard Brautigan for New Regency the
book which was first published in 1974
has reportedly been in talks to be
adapted for decades including
adaptations for Jack Nicholson Dustin
Hoffman and Tim Burton
in the high note which is available to
watch on May 29th a superstar singer and
her overworked personal assistant are
presented with a choice that could alter
the course of their respective careers
we spoke to stars Tracee Ellis Ross Ice
Cube and Dakota Johnson check it out
I feel like this movie couldn't have
come at a better time and you're
obviously the daughter of the legendary
Diana Ross so what was it about the
script that drew you to want to play a
musician and did you draw any
inspiration from watching your mom um no
I didn't draw any inspiration from my
mom and this character was so
beautifully written that I didn't even
have to look towards my mom's career or
life to bring anything to it it was all
on the page and I think what originally
drew me to this role was the overall
message and story that it was telling
and reminding all of us that it's never
too late to go after your dreams that no
age or a stage or phase of your life no
matter what people think even those
closest to you if they tell you to stay
in your lane that it doesn't mean you
should shut down that fire inside you
that passion and your dream to keep
moving towards what you want even if
it's a new direction and I love that it
was for both Maggie and grace that it
wasn't you know two women pitted against
each other but they were both sort of on
parallel paths of trying to find
themselves in a new way um and I loved
that I got to sing the film obviously
takes place around the music scene in
Los Angeles and I was curious how does
the music scene in Los Angeles differ
from say New York or Atlanta or any
other place I mean I think it's pretty
much the same in a lot of ways
everywhere you know there's you know the
companies that are you know at the top
of the game with the big artists and
then there's everybody trying to get in
the door or get their foot in the door I
think every city has its musical
community that collaborates and tries to
help each other make it and get through
the door
you know some industries are more
hip-hop driven someone more soul driven
you know I just think I think it's all
the same I just think the back job
changes you know it's people hustling
all people trying to trying to find
their dreams and trying to figure out
what a pity in this industry the music
industry seems like a vastly different
monster its own beast what did you learn
about the music industry from making
this film a lot mostly just like the
level of discipline that you have to
have in order to be successful in the
music industry for sure when I was
learning or trying to understand how how
to produce a song and how to work a
board or be in a in a recording studio
you know I've spent a lot of time in
recording studios but it's different
when you are wanting to be convincing as
a producer and it makes no sense to me
it's something that is just took way
over my head I love that's its own
special level of respect available to
watch at home today is the hunt
what is happening what is all of this 12
strangers wake up in a clearing not
knowing where they are or how they got
there they don't know that they've been
chosen for a very specific purpose the
film centers on a shadow of a dark
Internet conspiracy theory a group of
global elites who gather for the very
first time at a remote manor house to
hunt humans for sport but the elites
master plan is about to be derailed
because one of the hunted
crystal played by Betty Gilpin knows the
hunter's game better than they do the
film was directed by craig zobelle and
stars betty Gilpin Hilary Swank Ike
Barinholtz and Emma Roberts and
available to watch at home on Friday
debt collectors you still got it
you got every move though you with dense
I'm sore tonight Frenchie believe me
story for another time debt collectors
French and sue get to work doing what
they do best cracking skulls and
breaking bones as they chase down the
various lowlifes who owe money to their
boss Tommy they're summoned to Las Vegas
to collect from a dirty casino owner who
happens to be a vicious ex-lover of
Sue's facing danger from all angles the
pair will have no other choice but to
fight their way out of an explosively
dangerous situation all right well
that's it for today leave us a comment
and let us know what you'll be watching
I'm Cale anonymous and I'll see you next
time
and this Tracee Ellis Ross already
[Music]